London's underground it carries the
city's eight million people on a billion
trips a year there's a problem though
the city's growing bigger and that means
more stress on infrastructure so now the
UK wants to harness the internet of
things to make London smart and make
smarter investments into infrastructure
this research facility is trying to do
just that it's called the Transport
Systems catapult and it's finding ways
to make transport systems more efficient
the car goes over a bump we know where
the car is when it's internet-connected
the GPS location we can send that
information to a local authority there's
a pothole there please go fix it so
that's the kind of technology that we
want to make happen to improve the
efficiency with which the transport
system works in the case of the tube
that means monitoring Microsoft is
working with two other companies to
install sensors that monitor different
parts of the underground those sensors
monitor things like escalator vibration
and check for abnormalities or
temperature prevent overheating on
platforms and after your journey but if
you feel like hitting the shops the
crown estate has installed beacons on
Regent Street soon smartphone shoppers
will be offered discounts as they browse
even he throws newly opened terminal 2
features smart toilets notifying
operators when repairs need to be done
there's a
actual incentive to the intelligent
mobility market globally by 2025 we
estimate to be worth 900 billion pounds
per annum globally we want to help UK
business capture around ten percent of
that market with a 90 billion pounds at
stake for the British economy the
investment into making London smart
can't afford to be done